in this video I'll be giving examples
for subsets and supersets so if you look
at this blue line here this represents
our Universal set we've defined it to be
the integers from 1 to 11 that's 1 2 3 4
all the way to 11
don't let it concern you that there are
elements outside of our universe that
just means that they are I mean that
just means they're not in the universe
that we have in question right now so
it's no different than having stars
outside of your galaxy you're not
concerned by that it's just a matter of
that so if you look at this green line
what what set would that be well it
contains elements 3 beta and gamma so
this B B contains 3 beta and gamma so
this would be the set B likewise this
set here it contains elements 3 1 and X
well a contains 3 1 and X so this is the
set hey and finally this set contains
elements 1 & 3 this set contains
elements 1 & 3 so this is the set C now
what can be said about these sets well
we have we can say that C is a subset of
the universe because all elements of C
are elements of the universe furthermore
we can say that the set B is not a
subset of the universe because there are
elements of B that are not within the
universe also we can say that the
universe is not a subset that a superset
of a because there's elements of a that
are not within are not contained by the
universe and finally we can say that the
universe is a proper superset of C
because the universe contains all
elements of C except Al and there are
elements within the universe that are
not within the set C so if we wanted to
be more specific we could actually say
that C is a proper subset of the
universe